a escola a escola não ensina a pensar eu
sei
essa é uma afirmação drástico alguns
diriam radical mas isso foi se mostrando
verdade ao longo da minha experiência
como professora na periferia de porto
alegre no bairro restinga tem um autor
que eu gosto muito e já que se falou em
nazismo e fascismo
ele foi preso durante a ditadura de
pulso lima na itália
o antônio grammys ele diz que as
instituições elas são sofrem as
determinações do nosso tempo histórico e
eu digo isso pra falar que nós
professoras não temos culpa da
configuração escolar que temos hoje mas
ao mesmo tempo o grêmio e fala que uma
estrutura por mais rígida que seja
sempre possível abrir brechas e eu digo
isso trazendo também o grammy para falar
que essas determinações do nosso tempo e
essa ausência de culpa elas não podem
nos levar a uma desresponsabilização
pedagógica
elas não podem servir de desculpa educar
abrir brechas constantemente e eu trago
para vocês aqui
a brecha que tentei abrir a brecha do
perf a minha experiência escolar como
aluna é muito remota pra mim mas quando
eu lembro dela eu sempre lembro das
professoras e dos professores que me
ensinaram
eu raramente lembro do que aprendi com
essas pessoas
quando eu lembro do ensino da filosofia
por exemplo a grande lembrança que eu
tenho foi de um insight que eu tive
durante uma aula de filosofia no ensino
médio
em que estudávamos os filósofos que
vieram antes de sócrates e eu cheguei à
conclusão de que a palavra pré
socráticos significava antes de
softwares
essa é a única lembrança que eu tenho do
ensino da filosofia
pra mim isso não é ensinar filosofia e
foi aí
a partir dessa minha experiência ea
partir do ano de 2017 quando eu recebi
um presente da minha escola
uma turma que foi indicada pra sempre
para terem os alunos com alto potencial
de aprendizagem mas também com alto com
potencial de conflitos em que eu resolvi
fazer as pazes com a filosofia ou com a
experiência que eu tive com a filosofia
neste ano de 2017
eu trabalhei com uma turma de 30 alunos
que vinham carregados de preconceitos
machismo homofobia e violência além dos
dogmas religiosos que já traziam consigo
por conta das orientações familiares lá
na metade de 2007 estava completamente
apaixonada por aquela turma então lá por
outubro eu decidi que ao invés de passar
a turma diante pra outra professora como
normalmente fizemos na escola eu ia
junto com a turma para o 5º ano
trabalhei então com a mesma turma no
quarto e no quinto ano e eu como uma
pessoa ansiosa que som vivo de futuro
já em outubro quando desse dia isso eu
não vivia mais o ano de 2017
eu passava pensar no que faria no ano de
2018 junto com isso
se no brasil a proposta de reorganização
curricular do ensino médio
e aquilo me incomodou muito porque ela
deixava as ciências humanas de lado
secundarizado o ensino da filosofia e da
sociologia e prejudicar vá o pensar em
foi então que unindo isso a idéia da
transição da literatura infantil para
uma literatura infanto-juvenil
necessária nessa faixa etária em que nós
precisamos ensinar as crianças a lerem
livros em capítulos lerem diariamente e
não somente aquele livro infantil que
nós lemos todos de uma vez só é unir
essas duas coisas e resolvi trabalhar
com os alunos
o mundo de sofia esse livro que eu tenho
aqui
com isso eu esbarrei em várias questões
o mundo de sofia ele é um livro que
conta a história de uma menina que às
vésperas dos seus 15 anos começa a
receber cartas anônimas que o professor
de filosofia e essas cartas conto a
história da filosofia de uma questão aí
a escola pública não tinha condições de
adquiri esse livro para todas as
crianças
num primeiro momento pensei em 15 livros
para que pudéssemos trabalhar em dupla
a escola oferece 16 17 e o resto eu
teria que conseguir e aí eu fiz algo que
vai contra meus princípios porque eu
acredito que o estado o poder estatal
tem a responsabilidade de dar conta da
educação público
o estado tem o dever quais pó
a escola pública que garante a sua
estrutura e de garantir que o trabalho
seja realizado
porém veio uma outra contradição aí
pedir pra mim mesmo indo contra meus
princípios se mostrou fundamental no meu
trabalho e de verdade faz o trabalho faz
faz toda a diferença no trabalho de quem
está lá na ponta
e foi aí que eu fui pedir doações deste
livro
a campanha começou um tanto tímida e
depois toma uma proporção que eu não
imaginava
nós tínhamos a idéia de fazer esse
trabalho com a turma eu tinha idéia
essa idéia foi expandida para outras
três turmas da escola
tamanha quantidade de livros que
chegaram nós trabalhamos nesse projeto
conjuntamente com quatro turmas de 5º
ano
um dia um homem escreveu no facebook
onde eu fiz a minha campanha e falou que
estava recolhendo livros pra mim eu
nunca tinha visto
fiquei um pouco com um pouco de receio
mas dei o endereço da casa para que ele
fosse levar os livros em horário que em
que eu não estivesse sozinho quando eu
cheguei no portão do meu prédio ele
estava com três sacolas cheias de livros
livros que não eram só livros mas cada
livro
ao ser aberto tinha dedicatórias
especiais para cada criança
um outro dia eu recebi uma mensagem de
uma pessoa que faz muito jus ao seu nome
de tratamento magnífica a magnífica
reitora da usp dessa universidade
escreveu e disse que na reitoria estava
arrecadando livros pra mim eu fiquei o
topo
impressionado o que corretora tem a ver
com isso
quando eu cheguei aqui na ufa
imaginei ser recebida por uma secretária
não é recebido por ela e ela me entregou
a sacola dele mutti sofia e mais alguns
livros que foram para a biblioteca da
escola
todas essas doações elas foram uma
aposta de pessoas no meu trabalho
as pessoas não me conheciam
elas apostaram nesse mesmo processo
eu conheci uma pessoa chamada alexandre
ele foi estudante da universidade também
ele fez contato comigo enviou três
livros para a escola
nunca ouvi pessoalmente me mandou pelo
facebook
a dedicatória que deve ser colocada nos
livros e mantivemos o contato
hoje ele me faz lembrar dele todos os
meses da forma mais linda que alguém
pode ser lembrado
ele me manda livros todo bem e se chega
uma caixinha de livros alguns escolhidos
por ele
outros escolhidos por mim ele chegou na
escola são abertos em frentes na frente
das crianças e é sempre uma festa e às
vezes uma briga pra quem vai levar o
livro novo que chegou o dia trabalhando
o mundo de sofia e conversando com o
aluno que já tinha concluído a atividade
deixamos lhe aqui de horas foi ele que
deu esse nome fictício
ele me disse eu questionei a ele na
verdade o que ele queria ser
depois que terminar essa escola que ele
queria fazer e ele me disse soro
eu quero fazer um curso para lavador de
carro
aquilo me destruiu eu enchia os olhos
d'água em junho até hoje quando falo
nisso
e falei de george pode ser o cara que
desenha povos que projeta carros que
constrói casas
não precisa ser o cara que lava carros
não lavar carro seja uma profissão pior
do que as outras
mas o que me impressionava era o
horizonte tão curto
era um sonho tão pequeno e um aluno todo
brilhante porque o jorge era e ainda é
um gênio um gênio negro nascido na
periferia e eu me dei conta que dia após
dia
nós matamos na escola pública
boa sorte newtons simone se pouco a
então eu saí da escola naquele dia e fez
um desabafo no facebook o facebook é
como se fosse um diário para mim às
vezes eu coloco nele coisas sobre a vida
escolar e coisas que dão certo coisas
que não dão e eu escrevi o que tinha
acontecido e de certa forma me lamentei
para as pessoas
foi aí que surgiu um amigo meu que já é
amigo meu há um bom tempo o max olivetti
ele é um amigo meu do rio de janeiro e
ele escreveu no privado disse camille
quem sabe eu escrevi uma carta para
jorge falou da minha experiência de
quando eu fiz artes plásticas na ufrj
eu falei legal e foi nessa hora que eu
tive a idéia de unir tudo isso à porta
do max
a idéia do mundo de sofia em que a sofia
recebe cartas e eu pedi novamente eu
pedi
cartas a todos os alunos e eu não
preciso de ver que foi uma enxurrada de
calma todos os dias chegavam duas três
cartas em nome de cada uma daquelas
crianças várias vezes choramos pela
emoção com que as pessoas colocaram as
suas vidas daqueles pedaços de papel
algumas cartas foram respondidas outras
não
e nesse mesmo processo das cartas surgiu
a idéia de uma estudante aqui da
universidade também gira até a escola
realizar uma oficina com as crianças
uma oficina com o nome lindo que oficina
de sonhos
eles foram até a escola
falaram com as crianças sobre os seus
sonhos sem hipocrisia sem meritocracia
mas sobre oportunidades de realizar
missões e depois nós viemos até à
universidade
estivemos sentados nesse mesmo lugar
onde vocês estão e visitamos logo aqui
do lado
o museu de anatomia da usp foi um sábado
muito chuvoso que eu cheguei na escola
acham que não teria ninguém porque
chovia muito ea escola estava cheia de
crianças ansiosas para vir até aqui e
agora eu quero testar a conexão mais
importante que estabeleceu neste tempo
que na minha opinião foi a conexão
crianças mundo
eu trago aqui algumas conversas alguns
diálogos que fizemos na sala de aula
esse primeiro diálogo entre o george
esse menino que eu falei e o autor
os dois nomes foram escolhidos por eles
são nomes fictícios que foi após a
sempre coletiva do capítulo sobre platão
as crianças deviam copiar ao síntese que
fizemos coletivamente nos seus cadernos
um dos meninos disse chorando o pedro
não sabe copiar embaldo e outro
respondeu é só copiar pedro não precisa
ser igual faz uma cópia perfeita
fazendo referência ao simulacro de
plantão
o dia fazendo a síntese sobre o capítulo
da idade média e falando sobre a caça às
bruxas
um dos meninos disse chora parece
tráfico aqui na restinga quanto eles
brigam cortam cabeças
eu respondo pra vocês verem a idéia de
paz que passou mas deixou rastros
pois é só que agora eles evoluíram
é no tiro mesmo fazendo uma relação do
que acontecia no livro do que o livro
nos trazia sobre a história ea história
deles e eu trago aqui um pouquinho da
oficina de sonhos também em que uma
menina disse chorando eu sonho em ser
escritora
quando o livro é muito bom ele é
traduzido para várias línguas tipo mundo
de sofia nessa hora
então eu respondo fim ele foi escrito
por um norueguês mas o autor deste livro
é machista
ele só escreve sobre homens só tem uma
mulher aquela francesa simone de boal
isso foi uma conversa entre a florida ea
lorena as duas escolheram esse nome
esses nomes e foi durante todo esse ano
eu descobri que era possível estabelecer
conexões do particular com geral que eu
queria certeza de que é possível fazer
um bom trabalho na periferia um trabalho
sofisticado embora muitas pessoas não
acreditem nisso ou acreditem que
qualquer coisa serve
e foi assim que descobri que é possível
abrir brechas e educar para pensar